how's the gum breath where's Pierre 2pac
and welcome to a very requested game
it's called don'ts ARB I've been playing
it a little and it's it's it's pretty
cool game it's a horror mod called the
screech air and I thought that would be
perfect for Halloween perfect for me
perfect for you bros if you're wearing
pants but we're never that lucky are we
let's begin you pantless son of a [ __ ]
whoa damn pellet Creek January 1986 damn
this game is not [ __ ] around
oh no it's definitely not - the [ __ ]
dirt well what's that sound damn I
should go check it out find a flashlight
spacebar change ray this is awesome I
love how he walks but if it's a lunch
bag I can't wait here anymore I'm going
to try to call ahead at a helicopter I
left my flashlight for you see you see
Sara duffle bag all right we got
batteries this should be the flashlight
yes all right
right click to toggle it's just so cool
this doesn't even look like bone sir
am I like a condom or something it's my
tent oh [ __ ] it has battery life hey
let's go out so this game is actually
really creepy by itself it's once it
gets dark it gets really [ __ ] dark
ain't not it I don't like it we all look
how much better we lost already
helicopter this way I can follow these
signs to the helipad
we're gonna make it out of libraries my
cell left for dead hi you know I'm going
to the helipad you wanna come or one get
dead light away from me well I'm sorry I
just try to help whoa whoa whoa
who's out there I this literary [ __ ]
January 9 the helicopter just dropped us
off this place is amazing and the tour
guide seems really nice it is a so
peaceful out here no one no one around
for miles
that's it got it Oh God
why me it's fine it's just the game
about cotton woods and smelling grass
yes why you gotta be so spooky
let's just follow the road and it sure
will be fine okay we're [ __ ] we're
literally [ __ ]
hello I'm just a condom honest troll
looking for my home looking for my home
what the hell sir hello sir what are you
doing out here that's dangerous
okay what's going on why would you do
why the days what the [ __ ]
we're screwed fine let's ludus [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
something robbery I play is over there
okay god damn sure Sam Sam a pack of
batteries nice you know what's not nice
- [ __ ] douche bag that's what not
[ __ ] right I think my ears are
bleeding is there blood coming out oh oh
[ __ ] we gotta make a decision
all right now I'm not known for my
decision-making but there is a sack of
potatoes there and you bros know I love
my sack of potatoes junk all of it
cooler
I better be some beer Hill Creek map
simply amazing
this must be useful
so going right should not be a good idea
let's go right I'm just kidding all
right
we got it we got a loser right I think
oh god something's rotting in there
don't look at it that's what she said Oh
God
the helipad is this way should we try
and find all the note so should we just
try and get to the helipad I don't get
it it's a jacket here bill went looking
for the Brazilian kick Apple he still
hasn't come back I'm getting really
scared there's something out there in
the woods we need to get out of here I
must find the guy who the hell is the
guy aah aah
am I the guide I don't thinks it's a
circle let's walk this way around
god we don't have a lot of batteries I
really need some batteries
come on batteries ah come on
so I want to have a nice shiny decide I
don't like it one bit
we're taking there far way around just
to see if we can find some batteries
batteries and a Nana nanana nanana Nana
let the Tara Tara Tara down here we go
it's better be something game maybe like
a mountain Dew or like some chocolate no
[ __ ]
well that guy was beautiful he's [ __ ]
tall he's as tall as the trees man
whoever is out there I don't know when I
meow
god damn it what happened here [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ah okay ah my dear Adam shaft Bluff it
hunts those who stand
what what what is God what the [ __ ] is
that [ __ ] ha ha ha not Sarah not staring
not staring at all lalala where's the
bucket ha ha ha
where's that [ __ ] helicopter what'd
you say hey what is that road oh it's
the long road about the road so ok it's
all bad it's not God it's not good it's
not good we don't look at him don't look
at him don't want you to see him naked
that's the salty one every man wants his
privacy I can respect that
no problem sir no problem oh look it's a
Boomer let's not say ok we're going
we're going to it we're going to us but
go my bad my bad
silly me Oh God boom ah exploded oh [ __ ]
what's this just don't jump-scare me
okay
oh no fanny pack my sister's name is
fanny [ __ ] Oh God
Oh God we're gonna die breasts oh my God
we're so [ __ ] what is this what is
this the trees they're laughing at me
aren't ya
piece of [ __ ] we're going out track oh
god oh god oh god all right let's get
some battery [ __ ] in them I just want
to go to the helicopter bro come here
and sing along with my tampon songs
watch breakdown I am lost
oh god I'm right there
how do we get run-run condom n run we
could totally make it follow my hand oh
you're sweaty
okay a radio sure let's try not MIDI
Jack we thought you [ __ ] with Jamie
little shatter it ass soft a generator
wait generator isn't Hawkin once these I
let the helicopter oh how do I let them
ah
I thought we were gonna be fini Oh God
why me
they're not oh they're late are they
late
they don't look lit oh yes the generator
alright there we go hell yeah [ __ ] s1
goddamnit [ __ ] come on come on come
on come on walk walk walk walk you
please a joke yes yes yes freedom
freedom
Oh kill me ah
please be the helicopter please be the
helicopter pili I did it wasn't the
helicopter was it I don't start mud by
clay entertainment I managed to collect
seven out of nine notes it's not too
shabby far ah I like that that's fun if
you both want to check out this mod I'll
leave a link to it down below
I recommend it don't saris a really cool
game by itself so ah I didn't know they
had also mods like this though that's
that's pretty awesome I hope I can do
more in the future
and then I hope you boys enjoyed
watching and I hope you shaved your legs
because if you're not gonna wear pants
it's kind of weird if I go watching it
have to me a lot I really appreciate a
little support
it's the sky recovery with today I see
Bros in the next one
stay awesome love you that uh gonna
that's not what you think she she hit on
me I didn't know you she was together
with someone